il reste en effet deux grands prix à
courir en afrique du sud et en australie
prost veut sans doute une victoire
complète car il a annoncé qu'il irait à
kyalami le 19 octobre
à 30 ans il n'a qu'une idée en tête
gagner
dominique champeau nous fait son
portrait
je crois que ça doit être mon année mais
ce que j'ai acquis maintenant un maximum
d'expérience je sais ce qu'il faut faire
et ne pas faire pour pouvoir y est rude
au titre de champion du monde on a tous
eu à tous le droit à l'erreur pour ma
saison peut-être une photo d'eux il faut
essayer d'en faire moins possible il
faut rester concentré pendant toute la
saison ce qui est pas facile je crois
c'est ce que j'ai fait les deux
dernières années j'ai manqué un petit
peu de
peu de réussite l'année dernière j'ai
fait une ou deux erreurs 83 et 20 85
hassan khalil au premier concours de
cette année 1985 prost a pris place dans
le gotha des pilotes un cercle très
fermé qui ne compte que trois autres
adhérents jackie stewart
jim clark les kilos d'un tous vainqueurs
de 20 grands prix y est plus tous
authentiques champions
car si l'on prête beaucoup à la
puissance du moteur on oublie parfois
que le pilates est un athlète à sa
manière c'est pas vraiment un sport
comme l'athlétisme vraiment sont des
qualités physiques en premier lieu qui
sont demandées dai a des qualités
physiques des qualités mentales et c'est
un petit peu plus complet je dirais un
petit peu moins physique surtout en
performance mais sont quand même être
très long forme est bon
entre deux pilotes on peut faire la
différence et dit françois parisien
on peut avoir quelques quelques peurs
quelques chaleurs on arrive à penser à
l'accident mais mal à former partir du
moment où dans l'année dans la voiture
on n'y pense plus donc c'est toujours à
pour exhorter se passe quelque chose qui
se passe en occident est bon c'est pas
quelque chose qui me qui me vante à
l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui me fait peur
j'aurais aimé être de toute façon un
sportif professionnel et met dans ses
amis cyclos à aurait pu être le balaur
j'aurais aimé aussi être golfeur
professionnel ou même tennisman
professionnel un sport qui
qui me plaît vraiment un gain facile de
l'argent